good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is SCP 1788 object class
Keter special containment procedures
containment of SCP 1788 is currently
impossible embedded agents in various
governments including those who are
working to enact mandatory Rochin
screenings under the guise of
tuberculosis eradication as a means of
pinpointing SCP 1788 one instances any
suspected instances of scp-1730 command
personnel are not to engage suspected
instances and should retreat immediately
the foundation currently has seven
instances of scp-1730 contact with these
instances is strictly forbidden
outside of approved experiments each
instance is to be housed in a separate
humanoid containment cell feeding and
cleaning requirements are laid out in
documents 1788 cf no more SCP 1788 one
instances are acquired for current
research purposes any newly discovered
instances of scp-788 one are
preemptively cleared by l5 command for
immediate termination by armed mobile
task force tau for all things brightened
dutiful description SCP 1788 is a
process treatment or other means of
biological transformation a prepubescent
human being subjected to SCP 1788
becomes an instance of scp-1730 P 1788
is unknown groups of interests are being
investigated finding the origin of SCP
1788 is considered a Sindri
level priority on reaching adulthood as
CP 1788 one instances displayed
predatory behavior towards prepubescent
humans typically they will settle in a
large urban center find a form of
white-collar employment then begin
tracking prepubescence in the area
approximately once every six months an
SCP 1788 one instance will attempt to
abduct one of the prepubescence it has
been tracking and take them to a remote
or otherwise unobserved location where
it is subjected to the SCP 1788 process
and turned into an instance of SCP 1788
one little information has been gathered
from captured instances of scp-788 one
instances are of above-average
intelligence and show extremely strong
resistance to compulsion coercion
torture and other forms of information
extraction every instance to date has
also shown signs of malignant narcissism
and psychopathy they generally have a
complete lack of empathy while also
showing keen psychological insight for
these reasons among others unauthorized
contact with SCP 1788 one instances is
strictly forbidden individual instances
generally do not voluntarily gather or
interact except for the purposes of
mating in fact when two or more
instances are placed in the same
environment
they typically fight for dominance this
behaviour is not gender linked females
and males will fight one another in
addition to their own genders and then a
mixed gender group there will only be
one dominant individual who may be male
or female
captured instances are housed separately
to minimize damage multiple instances
have been seen in the same general urban
area but never in a ratio greater than
one in a hundred thousand normal humans
mating season apparently occurs annually
but is not seasonally linked instances
in some environments have been observed
mating in the summer while other
instances have been observed mating in
winter months as CP 1788 one instances
will exclusively mate with one another
they have no apparent sexual attraction
to normal humans gestation period for s
CP 1788 one instances is approximately
forty weeks roughly the same as humans
their offspring are genetically
indistinguishable from normal humans and
are not considered anomalous however as
they are prime candidates for undergoing
the SCP 1788 process their capture or
termination is to be considered high
priority second only to the termination
of a CP 1788 one instances s CP 1788 one
Anatomy it is extremely difficult to
distinguish an instance of a CP 1788 one
from a normal adult human even on close
inspection individuals shell variation
as expected from gender and ethnicity
but shares certain characteristics in
common as CP 1788 one individuals appear
to be obese within the range of 150 to
200 kilograms when fully grown as CP
1788 one instances have larger than
average eyes though not enough to appear
abnormal on casual inspection their
sweat contains high levels of potassium
and copper though still within the
normal range for an adult human though
externally normal their internal anatomy
has been extensively changed a CP 1788
one instances long bones and cranium
have been reinforced with several heavy
metals and their muscle fibers have been
interwoven with structures resembling
carbon nanotubes this gives them
durability strength and speed well above
the human baseline see documents 1788
1dx
for measurements and estimates level
three clearance is required SCP 1788 one
instances possessed backup organs and
systems for most of their bodies vital
processes for example they have a
secondary heart lower in the torso which
can work in tandem with the primary
heart to more efficiently circulate
blood or can function independently as
necessary certain blood vessels have
complex valve structures allowing
instances to close off blood flow to
damaged limbs and other areas to prevent
excessive blood loss other organ systems
also have two or three redundant backups
that can take over in the event of the
failure of the primary organs SCP 1788
one instances also possess a secondary
brain located in the upper torso and
protected by its own skeletal structure
similar in construction to the rib cage
currently the exact function of this
brain is unknown it is known that this
brain can continue to function even in
the event of the destruction of the
primary brain as demonstrated by
incident 1788 XR 12 the final difference
in the gross anatomy is the appearance
of a second pair of arms located
directly below the main pair these have
apparently equals strength and dexterity
to the upper pair an SCP 1788 one
instances are apparently capable of
using all four arms simultaneously when
not actively hunting instances hold the
lower pair folded closely to their signs
where they are largely concealed by
natural bulk when hidden in this manner
it is virtually impossible to
distinguish a clothed instance of a CP
1788 one from a normal obese human
except on close inspection
this is interview long SCP 1788 1 863
playing log now please state your name
for the record I'm gonna need a name
their children the driver's license and
other materials on your person
identifying us is that your name looks
my child's name I don't know demo refer
to you as 863 call me what you like just
don't call me late for supper you were
found by our agents outside an
elementary school and documents in your
car and apartment include multiple
photographs of children take them
without their knowledge are you a
pedophile age 63 if you're not a
pedophile at 63 then why are you
observing children you think they're
children I can't believe we came from
you explain what you mean by that
863 that's what I mean do you think you
can hurt me with that you're a failure
doctor you don't even know what you are
but you care to elaborate 863 you wonder
why your scientists haven't found any
anomalous implants in our bodies why we
have no surgical scars why our genes are
pure unmodified human because we are
human doctor your x-rays don't look very
human 863 we don't look like you
we're not failures we're not children
you regard us as children
you still look like children you aren't
finished
what do you are stunted incomplete
you're like the amphibian that grows up
to breathe water instead of air the eggs
I watch they must catch in to us they
need to be finished so you abduct them
to complete their metamorphosis we don't
need companionship
we don't live like you in herds each one
of us knows what we need to do and each
of us is capable of it and what do you
want us to do grow up or die
okay that about does it for today thank
you all for listening if indeed you
still are and you were all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Andre Bichette Pierce M
Hamlin Muslim Mookie Jax Merrick ki
Labuan slump God John Oh Porter
captain Gorge Tiber ball Judi Dench
cheese whip dips McGee I'm dr. mortis
thank you so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos found some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you